Jerry beads lost interest in the bank
stress tests a long time ago the
building contractor has enough stress
and tension to deal with with his own
very real banks we're looking at fifty
half built apartments and
underground car park built and holding
has been lying here since july two
thousand nine before the crisis beads
earned 40 million euros worth of real
estate now it's only worth a fraction of
that and belongs to the bags the
situation of the irish banks is that you
know did they're all sitting on a pile
of trash and and it's not getting any
better banks now have tens of thousands
of properties like these on their books
so despite the country's positive
economic data and falling unemployment
economists are warning against too much
optimism countries including Ireland's
still have a lot of death issues there's
still a lot of questions to be answered
so you know it's important to say it's
good news the art is currently doing
well but I don't think it's a it's a
it's a place where that risk by 2010
Irish banks had offloaded the worst of
their toxic assets into the state's bad
bank vehicle the national asset
management agency or nama nama has sold
off 16,000 properties for hard cash
including top holdings like this modern
Dublin theatre Jerry beads has come to
terms with the situation though like
everyone else he still complains about
the banks but wasn't he a part of the
problem himself we were told in 1999
that there was a hundred thousand houses
needed a year we're responsible for the
deaths and we are and we're being
followed them but ultimately in the big
picture the bankers are the people
created the merry-go-round that became
the Celtic Tiger Islands banks may have
survived the ECB tests but the echoes of
the crisis will resonate for a long time
to come